[Music]
in feel the music is submitted by pizza
a sign language interpreter steals the
show at Snoop Dogg's concert with her
enthusiastic translator I haven't seen
this but every time I go to a music
festival it's like the coolest thing to
watch because they're basically dancing
it's wordplay wait there's a musical
interpreter every single I like big ones
really yeah like the same one person who
is just like hired by reference like you
killed the Beyonce one come over here
for drink probably let me see
it's pretty nice pretty cool it's
basically dancing all right finger tight
you avin how do you even create this
watch.watch coordinated movement music
it is a dancing
[Music]
she's got musicality textures intensity
is crazy maybe like deaf people very
interesting but that's very interesting
that is in that person would want to go
to a concert yes why that's like a blind
person going to a art gallery
what so like I don't know what level of
death they are but if they're completely
deaf then can they like hear feel
vibrations or what I think that's
probably what helps so like they like if
you're in a music festival and you got
like heavy ass bass like oh you feel the
vibration so you can feel the energy
like you put the emotions to it you can
feel when it happens like I don't think
you can feel pity then you can see the
lyrics you see the [ __ ] beach oh my
favorite things to do when I went raving
was drop E and be inside of the speaker
box and feel the vibration on the bass
like just feeling that is pretty amazing
yeah that's true this woman her name is
Holly and if this actually isn't her
first time traveling
it doesn't look like
you don't have to tell me why I imagined
this girl's that evolution is kind of
like in the beginning it was super like
what but then she thought of feeling the
energy and then she just went all out
yeah you know so like she was actually
I'm interviewed about the Snoop Dogg
concert and so she was asked a question
of like what was it like for you up on
stage that day and so she says it was
pretty great sniffs energy was really
high he was really feeling the New
Orleans crowd and we had four or five
deaf patrons there and were all just
loving the show you know his shows
include dancers and a mascot and he kind
of goes through many of the songs which
he highlights which he highlighted on so
it was a really great high energy show
and his crowd was really into it and I
was very excited to be interpreting for
him and it was just a really great cause
I just love how she looks like a middle
school teacher like and just doesn't
really fit the branding of the music
because I just picture that if they're
gonna hire someone like an interpretive
whoever right then it just fits with the
whole squad like you know they just got
this whole Jamaican thing going on
reggae theme and then so I just imagine
like the interpreter is always also
gonna have like dreadlocks and they're
just like all in and you know it's just
it all works together and she was like
officially hired to do this yeah that's
so gangster yeah does she do all the
concerts like she does like death metal
and stuff - oh my god the only one I
know that she has done is with the
wu-tang clan I love it her resume dog
looting it's all [ __ ] yeah it's all
hip-hop reggae Senior Center
that's dope for sure yeah and so she was
like describing of snoops music because
he was just saying that you know his
background music has a lot of energy and
so as an interpreter you want to embody
what's happening in terms of the music
and the vibe and like it's so like you
know it's like so that you can his lives
become visually accessible connect the
vibration with the you guys ever seen
like sign language people argue that's
they have to convey it so like like
let's say there's like like this
whatever that's normal right but if
you're mad at someone is that so you'll
see two people share some titles with
body language yeah so you gotta convey
that she's feeling it's not I'm more
scared of that yeah you're killing it
right do you guys know any deaf dancers
yeah oh yeah explain that
yeah how do you think like how what
level of deaf like because like you know
how there's certain different like
there's different levels right like you
can hear some what and end there's just
completely it's kind of like being like
different levels of yeah vision it's
like a broad spectrum
yeah I don't know how do we know the
same person oh no I just know of a story
of a deaf dancer oh you don't even know
the person personally um I met a deaf
dancer once and he felt the vibration so
I don't think the music had to be loud
enough to where he could feel damn that
and I know of a person who can feel
vibrations but also they're on like a
urban choreography team so they're
relying a lot on like the frequency that
the teams at you know what I'm saying in
the following that Wow
and there's also a matter in the studio
too that kind of helps out yeah because
I know like once one of your like senses
go away then other senses become
heightened right so then they're
observant or they could feel things that
we can and I was just wondering like
what is it that they use to like so they
can dance what if you could just taste
better
this room you guys need to take a shower
you could taste the air
y'all stanky I'm tasting you think if
you if you had to give up up one sense
oh my god what would it what are the
senses some incense tasting feeling
hearing seeing smelling yes you would
give up taste yeah for real oh yeah no
I'm not surprised oh yeah because she
doesn't like food food let's rephrase
that because they don't know the context
of it so I do know my food know what
she's not she's not a foodie I'm not a
foodie yeah doesn't go crazy for food
like foodies do ya this is the most I've
been foodie because I'm pregnant so
there's no babies for real but besides
it's like being pregnant I just I'll
forget to eat I'm like I'll just keep my
food really bland like meat salt or
sugar or anything on it takes might be a
good one cuz it'll be easy to like stay
skinny oh I'm gonna give it a taste
I don't know [ __ ] about that then what
what happened
no because yeah I tried I forgot about
to be in trouble I know yeah ice cream
but then again but you can't get it back
so you know how good things taste but
it's gonna suck now because you can't
get it back don't you get a lot of taste
from smell yeah yeah yes I think that
smell would be the
I don't think giving up smell would be
better than giving up taste because the
scent is the express way to your mind
so like that gives like memories is that
right so scent would be very bad they
give up as would I think you'd give up
because if someone stinks then they'll
still be my what they smell good then
you'll never know oh yeah cuz I like
good smelling people to have probably
tasted
yeah prioritise I'm also seeing those
people that like don't have feelings so
they like bite their nails and scratch
themselves because they don't know what
it is why we what you know like kids
that are born with like out the ability
to feel so they'll like scratch things
and they'll bleed and stuff because they
don't know what it is so you have you
have to put like little mittens over
them and the positive side is you'll be
a crazy martial artist because nobody
can hurt you but the negative is that
but you don't know if you're getting
hurt yeah well you don't need to know
are you gonna die yeah you're just gonna
get knocked up cuz you keep forgetting
the block he's just gonna be you're not
getting conditioned to understand like
this is the not this is not a good thing
for me yeah so putting your hand over
fire [ __ ] it well why is it melting I
think we're gonna be like over eight he
feels yeah he'll damn it
so I got mutation it's like a deficiency
I'm just trying to be positive about
like not having one of these sense like
what is the good thing that could come
out of it everything else gets stronger
right so what's yours then
cuz if you're blind you could be a
dolphin I don't think you have fins or
breathe under you you can use sonar
technology and your hearing gets better
you know how crazy you're gonna [ __ ]
sound do you know who Charles is no Ray
Charles and Stevie Wonder they can walk
without canes
well resource is not alive anymore but
Stevie Wonder with which classical music
artist was deaf was it but they became
deaf they became and his ability to
compose was by putting his ear to the
vibration yeah that's toward the end
because he got like syphilis or some
serious good sound and yet her still
town yeah he's not like some crazy
genius
like that exactly when he was cast by
them yeah so uh Holly she was just
really excited to perform with Snoop
because she she wanted to make a point
that anytime a deaf person wanted to go
to a music festival the concert should
have like interpreters available for
these for example for those who enjoy
the concert
that's real cool mm-hmm cuz I I just
never think about it you know like when
people think deaf they just think
completely deaf yeah you don't think
that there's different levels of it but
then the music's so loud at festivals
you can feel the vibration and then just
the energy to like I don't [ __ ] drop
you no more but when I go to festivals I
can feel the energy and it feels like
I'm on ecstasy it's [ __ ] weird the
residual eat sometime yeah that's
residual it's weird but maybe it's cuz
I'm sleep deprived it's like 3 a.m. and
I'm dancing my ass off so I'm like on
adrenaline rush yeah but it's different
I'm not on drugs and I'm just like what
the [ __ ] just good memories man hey guys
I hope you enjoyed that episode of just
kidding News and if you guys want to
share a story there's a link down in the
description box below where you can
submit your story if you guys want to
watch more episodes click right up here
[Music]